سياسيا اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بلينكن تقديم مساعدات امريكيه
اضافيه لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليار و300 مليون
دولار وفي كلمه خلال مؤتمر اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا المنعقد في لندن جدد بلنكن
التزامه واشنطن بالوقوف الى جانب كييف
لاطول فتره ممكنه
ومساعدتها على التعافي
الولايات المتحده ستقف مع اوكرانيا مهما
طال الوقت كي تتعافى من العدوان الروسي
الكارثي من المهم ان نتحدث بالتفصيل عما
نقوم به لدعم اوكرانيا لكن يجب ان لا نغفل
ايضا عن الجانب الانساني التعافي ليس فقط
ان نوفر لهم الغذاء والوقود والدواء بل
ايضا من خلال تمهيد الطريق لاوكرانيا لكي
تنتعش كبلد امن ومستقل ومتجذر في سياده
القانون وكل استثمار نقوم به يرمي لتقريب
اوكرانيا من هذا الواقع واليوم اعلنوا من
خلال دعم الكونجرس اننا سنوفر مليارا و300
مليون دولار كمساعدات اضافيه وسنستثمر 520
مليون دولار لاصلاح البنيه التحتيه للطاقه